SHOULD.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT GOOD >>
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: FOR THE PAST COUPLE
OF DECADES, THE NATION OF
SWEDEN, THE SMALL SCANDINAVIAN
COUNTRY, HAS TAKEN IN MORE
REFUGEES PER CAPITA THAN ANY
PLACE ON EARTH.
ON 2015, SWEDEN GOT MORE THAN
160,000 APPLICATIONS, MAINLY
FROM SYRIA, IRAQ, AND
AFGHANISTAN.
SO WHAT IS THE EFFECT OF THIS?
EVA FLUTTERING HER BOOK DON'T
KNOCK DOWN, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
WE DON'T OFTEN ENOUGH IT TO THE
RESULTS, SO WE KNOW WHAT SWEDEN
DID.
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT?
>> WHAT HAPPENED NEXT WAS A
SKYROCKETING CRIME EPIDEMIC I
WOULD ALMOST SAY.
I MEAN, JUST A WEEK AGO WE HAD A
NEW REPORT COME OUT ABOUT LETHAL
GUN VIOLENCE IN SWEDEN.
AND IT TURNS OUT THAT SWEDEN HAS
GONE FROM ONE OF THE SAFEST
COUNTRIES IN EUROPE TO NOW THE
SECOND MOST DANGEROUS COUNTRY IN
EUROPE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
VIOLENCE IN JUST ABOUT TIME
PERIOD OF TEN YEARS.
SO THE EFFECTS OF MASS MIGRATION
AND DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE HAVEN'T
BEEN SMALL TO SAY THE LEAST.
AND STILL, MANY PEOPLE REFUSE TO
MAKE THIS LINK.
BUT I WOULD HAVE TO SAY THAT
ANYBODY WHO AT THIS POINT STILL
REFUSES TO MAKE THE LINK BETWEEN
MIGRATION AND THE RISE WE ARE
SEEING IN CRIME IN SWEDEN,
EITHER LIVES IN AN IVORY TOWER
OR HAS AN INTEREST IN TRYING TO
COVER UP THE TRUTH.
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT JUST TALKING
ABOUT LETHAL GUN VIOLENCE HERE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT GANG WARS
THAT ARE BEING FOUGHT OUT IN THE
STREETS OF SWEDEN.
EXPLOSIONS, KNIFE CRIME, NOT TO
SAY THE LEAST, SOARING NUMBERS
OF RAPES AS WELL.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY
MUCH WILLING TO COVER THIS UP.
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE SOCIAL
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNMENT IN SWEDEN
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS WOULD
CLEARLY PREFER TO HAVE THE
SWEDISH PEOPLE NOT KNOW WHAT THE
EXACT NUMBERS ARE AND THE LINK
BETWEEN CRIME AND MIGRATION.
SO WHAT THEY WILL DO -- THEY
WON'T EVEN MENTION THE WORD
MIGRATION PER THEY WON'T EVEN
MENTION CULTURAL CLASHES OR
INCOMPATIBILITIES.
THEY WILL JUST SAY OH, YOU KNOW
IT, THESE PEOPLE, THE
PERPETRATORS COMMITTING THESE
CRIMES, THEY COME FROM SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED AREAS.
SO BASICALLY A PRIME EXAMPLE OF
THIS NEO-MARXIST RHETORICAL THAT
THE MEDIA IS PUSHING TO COVER UP
THE TRUTH.
>> Tucker: SO SWEDEN GOES FROM
ONE OF THOSE SAFEST PLACES IN
THE WORLD TO THE SECOND MOST
DANGEROUS COUNTRY AND EUROPE
AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO RUN THE
COUNTRY PRETEND IT'S NOT
HAPPENING.
SO I GUESS THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN SWEDEN.
>> THAT'S THE ONLY CONCLUSION
YOU CAN TAKE FROM THIS.
THEY CARE MORE ABOUT BEING IN
POWER, CLEARLY.
IT SO THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
THIS NEO-MARXIST RHETORIC --
BASICALLY YOU CAN STILL KILL,
RAPE, AND TO BE THE VICTIM IN
ALL THIS.
AND THE EFFECTS ARE TERRIBLE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING IN SWEDEN.
IF THE PEOPLE OF SWEDEN DON'T
BREAK THROUGH THIS POLITICALLY
CORRECT CLIMATE AND THEY DON'T
START CALLING A SPADE A SPADE,
I'M AFRAID NOTHING MUCH WILL
CHANGE AT ALL.
IT'S ABOUT IS BASICALLY THE
FIRST STEP THAT SWEDEN NEEDS TO
START TAKING NOW AND IT'S MAKING
THE RIGHT DIAGNOSIS.
YOU CAN'T CHANGE WHAT YOU DON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE.
SO AS LONG AS PEOPLE AREN'T TOO
AFRAID TO SAY THIS OBVIOUSLY
DOES HAVE SOMETHING TO DO WITH
IMMIGRATION, SWEDEN NEVER USED
TO HAVE GANG WARS UP UNTIL THIS
DECADE.
THEN HOW IS ANYTHING EVER GOING
TO CHANGE?
AND WITHOUT THAT, THEY WON'T GET
TO THE SECOND STEP, WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY THAT SWEDEN NEEDS A
MIGRATION STOP FOR PEOPLE COMING
FROM THESE RADICALLY DIFFERENT
CULTURES.
SO YEAH, SWEDEN IS SO FAR BEHIND
IN THIS DEBATE THAT I'M VERY
WORRIED THAT IF WE DON'T TURN
THIS AROUND NOW, THEN THINGS
WILL LOOK REALLY, REALLY BAD FOR
SWEDEN AND EUROPE AS A WHOLE.
>> Tucker: THEY WILL LET YOU